the president says Democrats want to
defeat his nominee to run the CIA
because she works too hard against
terrorists Jena ha spell I made the
rounds again today on Capitol Hill ahead
of Wednesday's confirmation hearing
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Heron shows us tonight the
first woman nominated to be CIA director
went to Capitol Hill with the vote
coming down to a handful of senators
when Haspel will publicly testify to the
Senate Intelligence Committee today that
33 year CIA veteran met with staunch
critic Senator Dianne Feinstein as well
as fellow Democratic senators martin
heinrich and joe Manchin I'm anxious to
hear I'm very open-minded as you know
and I have curiosity to hear what my
other colleagues may have concerns over
and the answers that they'll receive on
Twitter President Trump said Haspel is
highly respected and under fire because
she was too tough on terrorists accusing
Democrats of lining up against the first
woman to potentially lead the spy agency
administration sources confirm that
hostile offered to withdraw her
nomination to shield the agency and
avoid read litigating the bush-era
detainee interrogation program critics
called torture she wanted to do
everything she could to protect the
agency at the same time she wants to do
everything she can to protect the safety
and security of Americans which is why
she is 100% committed to going through
this confirmation process the public
hearing is expected to put the Justice
Department approved program that
waterboarded 911 architect Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed under fresh scrutiny President
Obama's CIA director John Brennan was
one of the program's key decision-makers
and got Senate confirmation Haspel was a
mid-level manager with no say on policy
seems like we're making Gina Haspel
adhere to a much stricter standard
around this program than John Brennan
was ever held to account for I don't
know if that's because of political
disenchantment with President Trump the
ACLU said the White House may be over
playing the woman card there are a lot
of capable women
of both parties who are capable of
stepping into that role and being very
effective but there they would be doing
it without this enormous weight of
having been involved in the torture
program former senior CIA officers say
Haspel is a gifted operator who was
responsible for the capture of two
terrorists behind the 1998 al-qaeda
bombings turning the u.s. embassies in
East Africa today the CIA dropped off
classified binders for senators tracing
hospitals covert career as an
intelligence official confirmed to Fox
News Haspel will be back on Capitol Hill
tomorrow for a second day of meetings
Pratt despite the controversy she has a
lot of support from past directors and
past intelligence support from past
officials correct okay Katherine thank
you you're welcome